i
[Música]
1.4 millones es el número de dosis de
vacunas contra kobe 19 que ha llegado a
venezuela desde rusia y china- según las
cifras del gobierno del presidente
nicolás maduro 1.4 para casi 30 millones
de habitantes la academia de la medicina
ha dicho que menos del 1 por ciento de
la población ha sido inmunizada hasta
ahora sin embargo el presidente maduro
sostiene que en agosto aspira a tener
vacunados a 70% del país pero cifras
oficiales sobre cómo avanza este proceso
no existe la federación médica lo
cataloga como un proceso desordenado el
gobierno de maduro que ha sido golpeado
por sanciones internacionales dijo hace
poco que logró finalmente completar el
pago para acceder a las vacunas a través
del mecanismo cobas y que éstas podrían
estar llegando a venezuela en junio
hasta el momento los vacunados en este
país han sido políticos algunos
trabajadores de la salud y ha puesto
mayores seleccionados
los temas de la oposición del país ha
denunciado como un mecanismo de control
y mientras no hay un plan general de
vacunación continúan denuncias en las
redes sociales sobre un mercado negro en
el que se estarían comercializando las
dosis entre 70 y 200 dólares
[Música]
la campaña de vacunación contra el
coronavirus en paraguay se realiza en
medio de escándalos de corrupción y
fuertes críticas al gobierno por la
escasez de vacunas hasta ahora fueron
inmunizadas poco más de 200.000 personas
cerca del 3% de los 7 millones de
habitantes del país inicialmente el
gobierno de mario abdo benítez ha puesto
sus fichas por compras a través del
mecanismo kóvacs sin embargo esto
resultó en un fracaso y hasta ahora la
mayoría de las vacunas que arribarán al
país son producto de donaciones o
esfuerzos diplomáticos con países como
rusia e india paralelamente la justicia
paraguaya está investigando unos 500
casos de vacunaciones irregulares o
vacunaciones vip entre ellos el de una
senadora del partido de gobierno que se
vio obligada a renunciar luego que se
descubriera que accedió a una dosis sin
tener la requerida
mientras tanto paraguay sigue sumergido
en una crisis sanitaria con continuos
picos de muertes y contagios diarios de
kobe 19 y un sistema de salud pública
totalmente colapsado
[Música]
el gobierno de honduras firmó en las
últimas horas un contrato con la
farmacéutica pfizer para adquirir 4.4
millones de vacunas anti kobe y de esa
manera acelerar el proceso del país
menos del 1% de la población ha sido
vacunada en honduras según el colegio
médico la falta de gestión gubernamental
ha impedido que el país adquiera lotes
masivos de las vacunas para el caso
apenas en el mes de febrero ingresaron 5
mil donadas por el gobierno de israel
también un pequeño lote de la espuma
adquirida al gobierno de rusia por otro
lado el gobierno de el salvador hizo una
donación de 34 mil extras télica gracias
a una gestión que hicieron un grupo de
alcaldes de municipios con alta
incidencia del cob y el resto de la
población se queda con aprendes a
gubernamental de adquirir 14 millones de
vacunas y así inocular a más de 7.5
millones de hondureños elegidos